Good evening, sir.
Good evening. Good evening, Paul. Good evening.
Good evening. Good evening. Good evening, sir.
Good evening, sir. Good evening.
Okay, so let us start now.
Maybe sir has not yet joined
anyway, so I guess we can start with our
discussion first on the RNN
and then we will take you through some demo part.
That is what I have planned today for RN. Okay.
And then we'll see how to go to the next topic,
Sir, how one notes regarding the assignment?
Uh, so we are downloaded that, uh, three, uh,
2.89 GB of that data.
But, uh, when we are unzipping, uh, unzipping that one,
it is coming around 1.5 GB only,
and further it is not coming.
So, uh, while exhibition of the code also it is taking, uh,
means I'm not able to adjust that one properly.
So can you guide us in that one, sir?
Because actually I asked some of the, uh, classmates,
but I don't know whether they did it or not.
I don't know. So I thought better to ask you only. Mm-hmm.
Whatever data means, uh,
what is the total sample size you are getting
Total? It is coming around
2.89 gb. Sir.
No, GB is okay, but when you read that data,
Uh, when I unzip that one, it is coming
around 1.5 gb. Sir,
That is also, The information says there are somewhere
around 87,000 images.
It it's 7,000. Yeah. Oh, okay. Okay,
Sir. Uh,
we can directly use, uh, Kaggle hub.
Uh, we don't need to download any data.
Mm-hmm. Yeah. That is also one day
That saves in the cache and it is, uh, better also.
I will, yeah,
The, there's things you have to actually learn, right.
And just see that that's why this, uh,
timeline is given a little longer.
And when it comes to processing the IT seven, uh,
whatever is the thousand sub 87,000, you said, I don't know.
So that data is too huge.
I know that you may find it difficult to process it.
You can take sample of the data to build,
hold the pipeline and dock.
Okay. Just see that how much data you can process it,
Because initially I used that Kaggle online, uh, through
that one only, but it, it was taking around four
to five hours for, uh, this thing later.
I stopped that one, uh, later, uh, using, uh, I thought
that better to download that one, that option I tried,
but today again, I retread that one,
but, uh, it was coming around 1.5 gb, so I thought better
to ask you for the guidance.
That's it.
Although you have downloaded, if suppose you can keep it
in your drive, you can connect your drive
with the Google collab and then you can use it.
No need to upload that 1.5 GB all the time.
Yes, sir. That I did. Uh, let me recheck once again.
Those are the, those are the problems you'll find every
time whenever a new data point, new data set will come.
Yes, Sir. Okay. So there is no fixed way
because every data may have slightly different form.
Correct. So struggle in reading the data,
making it compatible with the model.
What you're trying to use will be there always. Okay. Yes.
Is what, uh, you can take help of the journey and all
and try to resolve it.
Thank you, sir. Thank you.
Yeah. But any case, it's taking a lot of time
to actually process it.
Yeah. A lot to optimize it, like Yeah,
That is true. That
is true. Just see that one.
If suppose you're not able to process complete data,
take the sample of data
and, uh, submit the assignment, that is also fine.
Okay.
Yeah. So we can, uh, reduce the number of s also
That you can take a call.
What exactly that is what we want to see there, that
what is the thought process,
how you have trained everyone might
have slightly different plan.
That is okay.
Okay. Last
You discuss about that L two regularization factor,
which was figured out in that,
Ah, so L two ization.
Uh, can you someone project that, uh, Brenda, what,
what the query, can you project it once on the screen?
Uh, so can I share it in the chat? Is that fine?
Uh, okay. You can share it in the chat. Do you have that?
Uh, no. I just wanted to see what is the question
and then want to see. Do you have that?
Uh, yes, sir. I have the question.
I have the screenshot sharing a title there.
Yeah, I sent it
In the chat.
Yes. Yeah.
So this one I see with
weight dk, is it equal
to 10 per minus four in the optimizer?
If the weight w is equal to 2.0, what do,
what is the L two penalty contribution to the loss?
Okay. Uh, uh, uh, so
what is the discussion which you want to have?
Or can you just repeat?
So, uh, there are two ways to answer this question.
So firstly, the formula, uh, the two formulas.
One is LW square and another one is LW square by two.
The second one is that we consider it while differentiation,
uh, to cancel the, uh, two,
which comes after the transition.
We divide by two and then do it.
So when we divide by two, the answer is 0.0002.
If we don't divide by two, the answer is 0.0004.
But the one which we have discussed in the class, uh,
remember there was one slide where I was discussing this?
Yes, sir. There it, uh, uh,
we have discussed one method for the L two regularization,
and, uh, if I can, I'm just trying to locate where it is so
that I can project, uh, a
and n Pause one second.
White dodge
just a second.
Present my screen. Now where it,
so, uh, this one I was talking, so this is
what we discussed in this course,
while explaining this L two regularization concept, we said
that the total penalty, this is
what you need to calculate, right?
So this is where you say it can be w uh, uh, by two also.
That is what you're saying, right? Yes.
Lambda Lambda
Two in summation of white Square.
Ah, got it, got it.
So Lambda bit two, uh, CI, what I say is
that the question was asked with respect to this concept,
what is, uh,
what is covered in this particular course, at least.
Okay? Accordingly, the answer was also fixed
that which is going to be, uh, right or wrong.
I understand that one by two always you can add, okay?
Uh, in, in that, uh, instead of taking Lambda,
we take lambda by two just
for our mathematical convenience, right?
That is what we discussed in the previous course also. Yes.
Why write the task function? Why we write one by two?
It is just for the mathematical convenience.
Because once we take the, what is that, uh,
partial derivative two will come, this site two,
two will get canceled, and then that will be easy, okay?
Uh, for, for the, for the, the rest of the calculation
what you're going to do next.
Okay? But so I, I think you're correct,
both the things are correct,
but I will still go ahead with this particular, uh, way
or whoever has followed, because at least in this course
and this slide we have discussed about this one, okay? So
Yes, sir. But, um,
I clearly asked ta when er asked ta
there was a similar question for the same, uh, thing.
Mm-hmm. Then ta clearly mentioned that for this, we have
to consider the division by two.
And for the other question, there is no need
to consider division by two.
That's the reason we went with that.
Oh, during, uh, exam? Yes, during exam.
'cause explicitly told to us that for this you have to go
by one by two factor,
but other, you don't go by one by two factor.
So that's why we had this option of other selections.
Oh, that is told. Uh,
are you there last time when we did, so I think
Was there not, um, snail,
Have you, have you discussed this?
Yes, sir. They have discussed what happened.
Means question number will be changed, sir, when we see
that is uploaded by the, Hmm, I have seen that question,
which I have seen that is different, sir.
No, no screenshot of the question.
Just know it was available right
number, forget about the number.
But the question itself, was it,
was it this question for which you discussed? Yes,
Sir. Sir divided
By two, sir. Yes, sir. They,
yes, sir.
They have discussed, but they have not displayed the
question, sir, on that time.
Yes, sir. We read the question out for, uh, ma'am,
They have read, sir, but they have not
displayed sir on that time.
Oh, but you gave the instruction to take divided.
Yes, sir. I have given, yes, sir.
But I have given the instruction, sir.
Mm-hmm. No, that I was, again,
this context was still missing for me anyway.
So then what we'll do, uh, so
we will just not consider this question also then
because there was a confusion, okay?
What they, what you suggested, right?
Accordingly, they have taken,
Um, because by reading that question, uh,
I have given the answer, sir,
because that question paper, I have not said it.
No.
Then you should not give the answer, right?
Yes, sir. Okay. Yes, sir.
Okay, Tika, then we'll not consider this also,
Okay, sir Tika, But both the things are true, okay?
Just said, uh, uh, uh, yeah, obviously
what was the instruction given that you have followed?
Then you are right at that.
So all of you have followed the same instruction.
Then we can consider that considering divided by two simple.
If you have considered, then we'll make other answer
as correct answer, whatever you are saying,
and it can still be considered.
But then there also should not be any confusion.
No, sir, I did not hear that. That very crucial.
Otherwise, you can give both, uh, options as correct, sir,
Uh, when either we should give both options as correct.
Yeah. In that case, those you have not selected these two
options, then at least they will be wrong, right? Yes,
Yes.
We consider that. Bye. Thank you.
Thank you, sir. Okay,
so now let us come back to our
RNN journey.
So now, first of all, let me just, uh,
hear from you, because in the last class server also asking
me whether at this point, have we made it clear to all
of you that what are the, uh,
architectural change we have done in the RNN as compared
to the a NN, right?
That is first thing. And are you able
to understand why the RNN is favorable, favorable
for the sequential data?
I mean, if this, this, these two, uh, should be, uh,
completely clear,
otherwise, uh, it'll be very difficult for going further.
Because when we are going for lstm, GRU,
little bit more complicated architecture, I mean,
if the par uh, the motivation is not clear
that why this kind of architecture we have to study
for sequential data, I mean, you won, you won't feel, uh,
much, uh, uh, you can say that the, uh, the, the effort,
what people have put while building
those architectures and all.
So I just want to spend some more time, maybe five,
10 minutes more to answer your questions
that whether have you understood the idea of this RNN, that
how it is different from a NN,
and what are the advantage it brings
for the sequential data?
Obviously, let us discuss that point first
with these figures
and all, I'll to explain,
anyone has still an query that, uh, no RN
and I'm not able to understand what is the difference.
So can you explain, uh, from war to oh three
or any other combinations, ah, uh, from oh three,
we're taking the fully connected, correct.
Again, 2 0 3, uh, yeah.
So can you explain this
Part? So
see what happened?
In the case of a NN, if you, if you have to process, suppose
a sentence where suppose you have three, three word, okay?
So what you can do is, uh, a NN looks like this.
For every input there is an output.
Now here, the input dimension is four,
output dimension is three.
But for every input x, there is an output.
O simple, you have to understand, but X and R not a scaler
or not a single, uh, value.
It is a, it is a vector set of values.
That is the first thing.
What you have to understand, you should not treat it
as 1, 2, 3, 4 inputs.
I'm feeding. That means four words. I'm feeding. Okay?
That is not the case here.
What I'm saying is this, X is a single word, but
because I have to represent the X in the form
of one hot vector, C,
every word is represented by one hot vector.
And while representing it as a one hot vector,
what is happening is every word is represented at here,
here, at least at five dimensions.
Similarly, sometimes maybe four dimension,
and essentially it'll be a V dimension.
Always. VV means
what is the vocabulary size for that corpus?
Okay? So, uh, what I'm trying to say, first of all,
that X is a single word, single word.
So what we do in the a NN, we feed a single word
and we get an output.
Output can be anything here.
The output is represented as three dimensional vector,
but it's a single, single output,
single input, single output.
Now, this is the structure of A and N. Okay?
Now, uh, it doesn't matter how many words you have
to process, you can, you have
to feed a single input and single output.
When I say single and put single output in the sense,
the X can be in window also,
we talked about it earlier, right?
So I can decide to feed the X
as three words at a time, okay?
Then also these three will be a single input single in
window where we have three inputs,
and then it will be a output for that one, right?
Yeah. So this is how the a NN works window,
you can decide whether it is a one word window,
two word window, 10 word window that you can always decide.
But that is how the a NN structure looks like.
But when it comes to the R-N-N-R-N-N, when it comes,
there is a architectural difference.
The difference, first of all, is you cannot process X one
unless you have not processed X, no.
So X node is also a word.
Say, V and x one is also a word, say R.
So we are in l, LM class.
So X node is a VX one is R.
So you cannot process R unless you have not processed V.
But if you see these two architecture,
it is, it is not the case.
We can be processed and then r can also be processed.
I mean, it is, it is something like that,
that these two are independent.
This network, uh, first of all,
it doesn't consider any sequence.
It can process, uh, either these two words together.
If my context window is of two word, or it can process one
after other RNN has architectural difference in the sense
when I have processed we, and then we are processing R.
So at the time of processing r the network has the sense
that it has already processed.
We, and that's why this, this connection,
this connection is coming from the last
hidden estate output.
But this is the architectural change,
which we don't have in the case of the A and n.
That is, that is the first thing
what we have to understand, okay?
So this is from the oh no to oh one timestamp.
Say that zero to timestamp one.
Similarly, when we go from time stamp one
to time stamp number two, time stamp number two,
suppose you have to process the third word.
You cannot process the third word
unless you have not processed the second word.
And obviously we cannot process second word
unless you have not processed the first word.
So this is how they are working in the timestamp ma manner.
So only change architectural syn.
If you see this connection,
the connection which is coming from the previous time stamp
as compared to the a n, n
and RNN, what is the architectural change in the NN,
we don't have this previous timestamp input coming
to this, uh, neurons.
But here in the case of RNN, we have one more input,
which is coming from the previous timestamp.
This is how from one to oh two, we go then
for oh two to oh three we go.
So we cannot process O three unless we have not processed O2
and so on for the other, other case as well.
So this is what is the architectural change.
Now, now let me know, uh, is it clear
or still you have any question? Yeah.
Yes, sir. I think we are sharing the parameters.
Yes, sir. I have one question. Yeah,
Please. So, sir,
uh, one thing is that, what I can understand is
that at every timestamp, we are processing one word.
Like at T zero, we are doing one T one.
So, sir, like you mentioned about the windowing
for the a NN part, can we do, we also have the window
for RNN, like multiple.
I see, uh, although you can have it,
there is no restriction,
but there is, that is not required here, okay?
We can make, still, uh,
we can make the architecture in such a way that at the time
of zero, I can process X node, X one together.
But suppose we are doing that. Suppose we are doing that.
First of all, we are losing the purpose that, okay,
we are processing two words at a time.
If we are processing two words at a time,
network will not network cannot make a difference.
Which word has come first, which word has come later?
That is the problem. And that is what?
That is the problem which we are trying to solve.
One of the problem which we are going to solve with R and n.
So we don't want to process,
although you can, you can process here at each time,
stamp the input in a window, but I don't want to do that.
That is the whole purpose that I want.
I don't want to do that. Okay? But you can do that.
I mean, it's just architecture, which we are building.
You can create architecture like that,
but it'll lose the purpose.
It'll lose the purpose of, uh, that order
of the word is not preserved.
Two words here. You're processing in parallel.
Two words here. You're processing in parallel two words,
or if you're fixing three word window, three words here,
you're processing in parallel three words here.
I mean, that will lose the word ordered itself,
and then your whole purpose is lost again.
Okay, sir? Thank you. Yeah, yeah.
Others? Is it clear
anyone still have any dot
Shall assume that the hedge value we take from the
previous times, step uhhuh is really representative of all,
all the H values, right through from the beginning till
that previous time.
So this is, this is the, i i, this is the ideal case.
This is the hypothesis, okay?
I mean, uh, that is what, uh,
that is what is the assumption.
Now, whether it is the actual case
or not, for that, we have, we have to do the experiments
and we have to check that, okay?
How long it is true.
And, uh, going forward, we'll see that this is the strength
of the RNN, that it can remember
what has happened in the past as well
as if the sequence length becomes very long.
Same thing goes as a limitations also, right?
So yes, it's just like a human's memory.
I can remember that what has happened in the morning,
what happened in the afternoon in my office, if you ask me,
okay, last year, 20, 25, 18th January, what happened?
I mean, it is very difficult to remember,
although I have lived that also.
I have gone through each and every moment, then also,
but then it is very difficult
unless something which is very important not happened.
Okay? So that is the case.
So yeah, the same thing, rn,
and it can remember everything from left to right,
but how long, okay, so how long, when that,
that question will come, then we'll discuss about the LSTM.
That why, that's why the LSTM is given. Yeah.
Okay, thank you. Yes.
Others? Any further question on RNN?
Yes. In the diagram? Yeah, the diagram which we had, sir.
So if I were, take this o as a hidden layer,
not in an output, the RN also, each neuron is connecting
with every neuron, correct?
Correct, correct. So I suppose you have one more layer
because it's a,
you see this net network alone, it is an ENN, right?
Yes. So an input, this can be first hit layer.
You can have one more layer here of the neurons,
which can act as an output layer.
Then what will happen, you know, all the neurons here will
also connect with all the neurons in this layer.
Yes, sir. Okay. That is also true.
That is that you can just imagine, see in the,
in the vertical sense, you can imagine each
of these network has an ENN.
So the everything which is true
for an n will act adhere also,
Sir, Only thing is r and n makes us different just
because it works at the time due to these connections,
which is coming from last year
and instead, was this your question
or anything else you were asking?
Yes, sir. Because this connection is there in a
and n also, if I am stacking it vertically,
Ah, this connection is there in a and n also
E, Yes. This
connection is missing. This blue one,
what you're seeing, I'm corresponding yet
that is not there in the a n
In the final layer, final hidden to output layer.
It is things that is the blue one, sir.
Uh, the blue one is the, the,
the whatever hidden layer you have here, okay?
Yes, sir. That also gives the connection,
that also gives the connection to itself.
So see, this is the con, this is the loop.
This is this loop, which I'm talking actually,
Yes, Sir. Okay. So,
uh, i, it is feeding itself.
So the hidden layer is connected
with the hidden layer itself.
Suppose you have one more hidden layer here,
one more layer here.
That would have also be connected like that here.
That would also be, so each layer here will be connected
with the other layer in the corresponding network.
So you have to imagine every network has an ENN in the RNN,
what would happen, every hidden layer output will go
to the same hidden layer in the next time stamp.
If there are two stack layer here
and two stack layer here also.
So these stacked,
these three neurons are connected with these three.
Maybe another three would have
connected with another three here.
Okay? That is how it is, uh, connected.
So hidden is connected with itself.
That is what makes the RN different from the single.
So suppose there is no loop, then it is an ENN.
Suppose there is a loop, then it is an RL, yes,
RRN, yes, yes.
Thank you. Yeah.
Okay. So, uh, couple of things.
First of all, that, uh, this is if you will collapse this,
uh, uh, this whole, I mean, it's detailed network.
It'll look something like that,
that you have x not time Stamp number one goes
to the hidden, hidden layer.
You may have one more, uh, neuron here.
I actually, I'm not showing you that one,
but that is all, all possibly.
Then what will happen, you know, if,
suppose you have one more neuron here on top of this, okay?
For example, what I'm saying is that, okay,
suppose you have one more neuron here.
So thi this will be a connection,
and this is true for any NN, right?
ENN, it is connected like that here also,
you'll have one more neuron here also,
you'll have one more neuron.
Now, how the connection will be.
Now this neuron will be connected with this like it is here,
and this is connected with this.
Now, they will not be connected. This is, this is not valid.
This is not valid, okay?
This will, this is not valid connection. Okay?
So that's what I was trying to say.
Uh, in the other case, case also, that, just a second.
Uh, yes.
So here, this, this, these are the hidden layer,
suppose so this hidden layer.
So because there is only one hidden layer connected
with the first hidden layer, can you first,
so suppose there is one more hidden layer.
That second hidden layer would have connected
with second hidden layer here.
They will not connect each other when there this connection.
Now, vertical connection will be there from her hidden layer
to another hidden layer, but across the time stamp
connection will be from the same hidden layer.
So this is the same hidden layer here,
but across the timestamp.
Okay? So that is what you have seen,
that this timestamp is connected
with this, with the hidden layer,
The, this process of, uh, this process
of training like this will lead to more number
of parameters, right? Compared to A and N,
No, that is another contribution.
Yeah. So, uh, the contribution, you see this
what is written here, UW, uw, uw, doesn't matter
how long you will go in this x not to action, you can go,
but see these parameters are shared across timestamp.
Across timestamp.
So suppose you have here 10 parameters and here 12.
So in the whole network,
whether it is a hundred word network or 50 word network
or three word network, you will have only 12 plus
10 22 parameters.
The parameters doesn't change,
and there is a purpose of that, right?
If suppose we change these weights, how do we remember that,
what we have seen in the previous?
Because these waves are the representation of these inputs
X nod through, you only represented here X one.
So what what we are doing is when we feed, next time we
update the last one, what we have used at the timestamp.
So at the timestamp number zero, we used the weight U
already up U is updated by X, not a little bit.
Now, what, uh, update in the sense that this weight, uh,
we have used to represent X no,
here in this particular neuron, now I'm trying
to represent the same so, uh, uh, weight here
to represent X one.
Also, because I want to preserve the context.
Context, the context being preserved in two ways.
First of all, the output,
what we are getting here in this neuron,
and that is we are feeding so that it remember that, okay,
last time I processed this, and these, the weights also
because we are keeping, uh, uh,
and later on we'll do the backward position.
So, uh, it, it also gets updated based on ba uh, uh,
whatever, uh, the context, what we are
feeding in the form of X.
No, the next one, the next.
That's why, uh, we keep the number of parameters same.
So in all these, in, in hidden to, sorry, input
to hidden layer and hidden to hidden layer.
So this is the connections,
which we have only two connections we have, right?
So we share those parameters,
but in the, uh, a n there is no sharing
of the parameter, right?
For every input project, snow dial pass, okay,
we'll have one, uh, one, one set of weight,
and then, uh, it'll go, okay,
and then it'll come here, fine.
And then, then you may update the weights,
and then you will have the X one going,
the next two going, right?
So, uh, this is, this is how the, you can see that A
and N is different from the, uh, RN Yeah,
because we are sharing the parameter, okay?
Yeah.
Uh, sir, in short, we can say that in RNN, both the hidden
and the output base are shared across, uh,
various timestamps.
But what exactly is, uh,
the data which is getting propagated, uh, through various
and, uh, networks of each timestamp, is that, uh,
of the data, which is coming from,
from the output of the hidden layer?
Exactly, yes. This is what is happening. No, sir.
Yes, yes, that is what is, okay.
Okay. So thank you, Sir.
One question is that sir, UNW will be same across the
Whole all the time stamp across all the time stamp, yeah.
Okay. Yes.
Okay. Okay.
So now, uh, uh, I,
I don't know sir has connected or not.
Uh, okay,
Where, uh, so here, here, okay,
so if I will formally define the RNNA recurrent neural
network, the neural network designed
to process the, you called me.
Yeah, sir. So, uh, I can just, uh, making sure, uh,
that everyone has understood
what is the sequential nature, uh, the data mm-hmm.
And why the RNN uh, network is preferable for that.
Mm-hmm. So, because that, that's
what we were discussing in the last, uh, got all of them is,
uh, so just having that, that discussion.
So now, sir, uh, what I have planned is that I will just,
uh, take them through one demo
and I'll show them that how to build this iron architecture
for one, for one, uh, data set,
and, uh, maybe then if the time permits will go
to the next parts implementations and all.
Is it fine, sir or planned anything to Perfect.
Okay, thank you.
Thank, Okay.
So, uh, this is one, uh, miss, with, with one,
one, uh, you can say equation,
we can represent the whole RNN,
where it r this every output at a particular times.
T is a function of, suppose XT is an input.
Then U is in weight, so XT into U plus.
The last output is OT minus one into W,
and whatever is the bias which is connected here.
So this is one function, uh, with
through which you can represent the output,
what you're getting at, at the RN cell, right?
I think you have understood this.
So this is how we process it.
Uh, you can feed first time,
first word from the given sentence, second time,
second word, then third, fourth.
So what we say at the last time,
stamp whatever you are getting the vector,
that vector has the complete context understanding.
Say that of the sentence. I love deep learning. Okay?
So I, we get the output here.
Also here, also here, also here also.
But every time, uh, uh, we'll talk about the different types
of the and architecture in which you can use it.
But here, what I'm doing is, for me,
getting the output at the final timestamp is more important
because here I get all the words processed,
and here, whatever output I'll get,
that is the representation of complete sentence.
You can say that, right? So this is how we process it.
So final state
or three in quotes, the context of the entire sentence,
and this is how you can process, right?
So, uh, parameter I have talked about, uh, in, in the,
in the case of, uh, RNN, it is, uh, shared parameter.
So you have whatever is the parameter
between input and hidden.
Hidden layer means input and hidden layer
and last output to the current output neuron.
What there is some weight.
So these are the, uh, parameters along
with the biases you have in the entire network.
And that is true for, uh,
that is shared across all the time step, okay?
So now what I will do is I will just take you
through one, uh, demo.
So maybe that, uh, you will understand, uh, where it was
second, just give me,
Okay?
Yeah.
Okay. So I'll just take you through this demo, uh, uh,
let us see how much you will be able to understand from it.
I will take you through the internal,
internal architectures, a, uh, that, how
to build the RN in itself.
We will, we'll see that a little bit.
So first of all, uh,
I will run completely once again.
So what I'm doing is, uh,
I'm using one data set from Kaggle.
Someone was telling, right? Was telling, right?
We need not to download the data and then upload.
You can use the Kaggle hub.
This is the package, and if support,
the data is available in the Kaggle,
you can directly use in the Google, right?
So this is how you can do it.
You can try for the assignment, what it is given to you.
What I'm doing here is I'm just importing some
of the packages, which is required to build design network.
And because the data set is very big,
I'm also using the GPU, okay?
This we have already seen in the previous notebooks also,
but this line of code is about
downloading the data, okay?
And data from the Kaggle.
And this data is the IMDB dataset,
the sentiment analysis IMDB dataset.
So if you go to the Kaggle, IM DB
dataset, you will find it.
Uh, so this is the data
what we have, okay?
And if you go down here, you have, uh,
these are, this is how the dataset is.
It has, uh, I guess two columns.
First column is about the review, okay?
And second column is about the sentiment.
The sentiment is only two binary classification problem.
It is either positive or negative. That's all. Okay?
And it's a movie review.
So usually these reviews are very long, the paragraph wise,
like pipelines, maybe 50 words or so, okay?
It's not a four word or five word.
So that is the case in this particular data.
So you can also use it, uh, if you wish, uh, just
by using this import gaggle
and using the, this, this, this one, you have to give, okay?
So, and you will find it here itself.
Whenever you go to the Kaggle
and you try to download the data at that time,
it gives you the suggestion whether you really want
to download or you want to use it just in, in your, uh,
collab or wherever you're writing it.
So you can just use it like that. Okay? So yes.
Um, sorry.
So what I'm doing is I am getting the, uh,
path means for, from, from, from this.
I'm getting the path directly from, uh, on the AL hub.
And then what I'm doing is I'm making use of the pandas
to read the actual data, just to get,
getting the path from this line, whatever.
I'm, so this line path, it is written,
this is the path, okay?
Which I'm using here using the os uh,
package and package.
Then I'm able to read this data.
So now the data is available.
You can see that data is like, this is how many,
50,000 rows and two columns.
First column is for the review.
Second column is for the sentiment, okay?
This is the data set we have data set is too huge.
So I'll show you that,
that I will not be using the complete data set
for the training, otherwise it'll take more time, right?
So I'll use a sample of the dataset for the demo, okay?
Uh, and uh, there are two reasons for this.
First of all, here you see that, uh,
I think it is still training, right?
Okay, it's still training. So here, if you see that, uh,
I have tried to print one data point.
The first data point, this one, one
of the other reviewers has mentioned,
you can read this, right?
One of the other reviewers I mentioned,
and it is still, uh, uh, uh, it is still going after this.
Also, this is not the complete sentence,
what it has here, okay?
So the reviews are a little longer.
You can see that more than 50, 60 words, uh,
it might be happening around a hundred words
also in a single review.
Okay? So it's a, uh, paragraph wise, uh, uh, data wise,
what I have, so, uh, this is just a, a sample that
what we have read 50,000 reviews,
and it is labeled with positive and negative.
This is one of the sample. And
what we are doing here is from this data frame,
a review called a data frame label column.
I'm just trying to, uh, uh, extract those review,
which is in the column of sentiment.
You can see here, right? Positive, negative,
and mapping that one as zero one,
because sentiment is either positive or negative.
So we have to convert it as zero or one in order to process
and, uh, for the training for the right.
And that is what this line is doing.
Simply mapping the positive as one
and negative as zero, that's all.
And then after this line,
if you see the dataset looks like this.
So review column is still same 50,000 rows
and uh, label where it was positive or negative.
Now it is showing as one
or zero just by this map function, okay?
And given that index, that's all.
So this is the first level
of pre-processing we have done converted the labels,
which were in the text into the index zero one.
Now here, you can see that we are just sampling, okay?
Some dataset. Uh, so out of the 50,000,
I'm just taking 5,000, okay?
And, uh, these 5,000 dataset is
taking randomly, okay?
5,000, uh, uh, and, uh, random statistical to 42.
We talked about it earlier also, that in order
to reproduce your result, uh, we usually keep,
the random estate means the seed value, seed value in which
the randomly 5,000 data would be selected would be same
for every time when you will run this particular case.
Otherwise, because you're randomly selecting 5,000 data
points out of the 50,000, those 5,000 row can be
any 5,000 rows, right?
But the seed value ensure that the 5,000,
what you're selecting randomly will be same,
obviously it'll be random, it may be zero rows,
or it may be 10 rows, or it may be 50,000 rows or,
but whatever it will be, it'll be same every time if,
if this see the seed value, okay?
That is the purpose of this, this, uh, whole, uh,
this particular line and this line is simply
doing the train test split.
We have seen it multiple times also,
although I'm not, uh, using it,
but you can use it if you wish.
Now, because, uh, I guess, uh, at least in this course,
we are, uh, working with the text data.
I think for the first time, I thought I'll show you a little
bit of tokenization part as well,
because those things are very important.
In the case of the text data, like in the case
of image data, there was slight pre-processing
for the image was required in case of to be compatible
with whatever model CNN model
or V 16 model, what you have, what we have used.
Similarly get the text.
Also, you have to do some kind of pre-processing right here.
Uh, once we have any text, text, I am saying
as every review will be the text, okay?
Now, every review, whatever we'll have,
will apply some pre-processing on that.
The first one, uh, is once this review will come here,
I'll convert them into the lower case,
because some, uh, some you can see that here it is,
it's, I is capital.
Here it is, security.
S is capital, maximum M is capital and state as is capital.
Uh, but you can see that here, uh, uh,
maybe some other words, which is starting with the, uh,
small, small case, some word which are starting with the,
uh, capital, capital letter or small letter.
So it is possible the same word is somewhere starting
with the small letter somewhere.
It is starting with the capital
letter, the same word, right?
So tokenize should not read the similar word
just because the, the first letter is capital or the small
or any, they're represented as a capital letter
or small letter, okay?
Because this is a review which someone else has written
and they might not have, uh, followed.
Uh, they might have written it
how they want to write it, right?
So what we ensure that I convert everything
as a lower case just
because, just, just to remove any kind of a tendency, right?
A similar word should not be treated
with two different indices.
So that is first things, what we do in the pre-processing.
Then we are also replacing some of the, uh, like, uh,
things like you can see that, right?
We are, and then these are some of the, uh,
things which is available in our, uh, uh, uh, uh,
in the text, which is not required here.
While data collection,
these things might have come from the STML and all tag,
and also that is not required.
So what I have decided, I will resu remove that also.
So this is also will be removed.
Then if the po there is any atrophy sample, right?
Uh, that also will, will removed
by nothing means it'll be just simply removed.
And then finally, after doing these three pre-processing
final thing, what we are doing is we are doing the split.
We are doing the split. Okay?
Now I can show you that, that
what are the things we are doing.
Suppose I will take this just
because I want to show you that I will take this also.
So, uh, I will put it somewhere in between. Okay?
So here I have put, now I'm just calling this particular
function tokenize, and it'll do all these four things
and return the final tokenize text for us.
Okay? So I think the it is done. Yeah, it is done.
So now I can run this once again. So let me just see.
So when, once I'm running this one, what is happening is,
you know, now inside this particular sentence,
this is a text here,
it will convert if suppose we have something in capital,
say O one O was capital,
but now you can see O one O, it's small.
That is first thing what we are doing in the first line.
If somewhere we have these tags, it is removing that.
Also, there is no tag, which is coming as a token.
If somewhere we will put any epitopes that you will, right?
So you can see that how it is now ULL, it has come,
obviously it is wrong, but it is, it'll do like that,
the pre-processing and all.
So likewise, you can plan that. What are the pre-processing?
Uh, it is required for the data
because every, every data, what you will collect may have
slightly different kind of pre-processing,
which is required, right?
Some data might be very clean,
some data might have these kind of tags.
It depends, right? So that you can take a call.
This is not fixed that these are the only
pre-processing you have to do.
But likewise, you have to do some pre-processing
and you can take a call, which pre-processing I have
to do, okay?
This is just one sample, uh, text.
And it, uh, this, this function will call
for all the 5,000 sample, which we are going to use, okay?
And these pre-processing will be applied on that. Okay?
Now, once we do that one tokenization,
so once we tokenize why we are tokenizing,
as I said you earlier, also, we have to build our vocabulary
for the corpus, whatever we are using 5,000 rows,
uh, randomly sampled.
So we are going to build the vocabulary for
that vocabulary means unique token.
So it may happen that the is coming here also,
the might be coming in some other world also, I don't want
to count the two times.
So for the, I will consider unique, uh,
unique entry in my vocabulary.
So like likewise. So I will now build my vocabulary.
Now, when I'm building the vocabulary, what I'm doing is
I'm starting my dictionary like this,
this is a dictionary, okay?
D dictionary. And there are two predefined
elements in the dictionary.
First one is the pad,
and second one is unknown.
Second one is unknown.
Uh, we'll see the pad, uh, is required here,
or not any, anywhere.
We'll see that one. But unknown token will be using very
frequently wherever.
Suppose at the test time, a new sentence will come,
and that sentence, when we tokenize, a new token comes,
which is not there in my vocabulary,
we'll assign it unknown.
That's the purpose of unknown token
pad usually requires when you have
to do any kind of padding, right?
So, uh, uh, uh, padding, uh,
we will do here,
or we'll see that one whether I
have any text like that or not.
But padding is required. Suppose you want,
you have some sequence of length
and you want to make it, uh,
usually padding is used when you process
the data in batches.
So when you process the data in batch, every sentence
or every paragraph has a different length, right?
Suppose you plan to pro, uh, plan, plan to, uh, process
five, uh, uh, five rows together.
Every row will have different length.
Now, in that case, pattern will be required
that you can fix that, okay?
Every row, I will, I, uh, I will process this many
because every row may have that right different length,
and you want to process it that in the badge.
Yeah. So that is one case use case of the pad,
but I don't see that I'm using any,
any such case in this particular core.
But you can always have these two predefined tokens.
And now whatever unique token will come in my corpus
that will be assigned,
and an index number starting from two zero,
and one is already occupied.
These two are the tokens in my vocabulary
and whatever new token will come,
they will be assigned the token number two,
token number three, sorry, uh, index number two,
index number three, index number four.
And it can go as, as long as unique tokens you are getting.
So that is what this particular function is telling.
So you can build your vocabulary, receive the text,
text in nothing but text in nothing.
But these, these, these things.
What you're going to get means reviews.
Like you can take this as first text means first row, then
likewise, 5,000 you have.
So one by one you will get those 5,000 rows.
And every time what you will do,
you will call the tokenized function.
So tokenized function, when you're calling,
all these operation will happen, okay?
And after tokenization, what will happen, you will get,
for every, every sentence
or every paragraph, you will get the tokens like this.
Now, every token would be checked whether it is available in
my vocabulary or not.
So that is what for every token, what we are getting,
we'll check if that token is there in the vocabulary or not.
If token is not in the vocabulary, suppose I will start
with the first token one.
No one is not available in my vocabulary currently.
So then what will happen if suppose I'm processing one
for the first time, one is not available, then
I will create a new entry here like this.
So I will create like this, this,
it'll create automatically, it'll create a new entry for
one, and it'll assign the index number to, this is
what it'll do here in this particular case.
So why, why vocab token?
So vocab is the name of my vocabulary,
and token is the name of this token.
One eco it assigned by what length
of the vocabulary, what is length of the vocabulary?
Initially, the length of vocabulary is two,
and that's why, uh, next time
whenever to new token will come, will be assigned with two,
and that is a unit token.
Next time what will happen, now the length
of the vocabulary is three,
and next token is coming as of, so what will happen again,
new token will be created with the name of
index will be three.
Now, now the vocabulary, so it,
it is depending on the length of the vocabulary
and length of the vocabulary is always one lesser than
whatever number of token you have,
because you start with a zero.
That's why. So you can always give that length
of the vocabulary as a new index number
for the unique token.
Whatever you're getting now, this is what will happen, okay?
Now, this is what this particular function will do,
and uh, this is the function.
And now here, uh, this, in this part line,
actually we are executing that function.
So we are calling this build vocabulary.
This is the function name, right? This is the function name.
We are calling this one and applying this function on my
review column of my dataset.
See that this is the review column of my dataset.
So one by one, each row 5,000 row,
what we have decided will go here
and it'll keep on growing our vocabulary
with this particular line.
Okay? And finally, I can simply count this vocab length,
so length of my dictionary vocab,
and then I will get to know that what is the total number
of unique tokens which we are getting in our vocabulary.
In this particular case, it is coming as 75,509. Okay?
Four for how many?
For 5,000 rows only if you will use 50,000 rows,
which is the actual data size, right?
It'll be in lax, I guess.
Uh, uh, it may be, I don't know,
but you just check that one, it, it'll be too huge.
At least here it is, 75,509.
So must be more than one lag, I guess, right?
So yeah, this is the next step that building the vocabulary.
Now, once you will build the vocabulary, you have
to convert the sequence of word as a sequence of
indices, right?
That is very important. We talked about it earlier also,
that your, you don't want to lose the sequence information.
So this whole effort, what you're doing is now you will
represent your sequence as a sequence of indices.
Now, this fourth step is doing the same thing.
Convert text two indices.
Text two indices is the name
of the function, which we're defining.
It'll accept two parameter text.
And what is your vocabulary, which you have just built,
because in the text, what you will do, you will apply
the, the, uh, what is that?
Uh, the tokenize to token.
Whatever text means each row, you will pass it
through this particular function from your data.
First of all, it'll apply the token izer
for each unique token.
It'll see in the vocabulary
what is the index number it is already given,
and that is what it'll assign.
Okay? Now this whole thing is doing that part.
So first of all, it'll do the tokenize,
what is written here.
Once it'll do the tokenize, then it'll check if
token is in the vocabulary token in the vocabulary, then
whatever is index number, this returns the index number of
that particular token v vocab token, if you will put,
it'll return the index of that particular token.
Uh, right? So if token is in the vocabulary,
return it index.
If not, then re, uh, whatever is the, uh, index number
for unknown token to assign it.
So for every new word, if it is not that in my vocabulary,
it'll be assigned the unknown unknown token index number.
That is one. Otherwise, it'll assign that index number.
Now, that is what it is doing here in this particular code.
So just to test, I'm calling this text to indices
and passing this particular one sentence.
This is one sentence, and this is my vocabulary, VOCA.
You can see here vocabulary. Okay?
Now, once you'll pass this, uh, sentence,
the text info vocab, then for one, the index must be 1 62.
That's why it is assigning for 1, 1 62.
Actually, you can check that also.
Uh, what you can do is
after this, if I will write
vocab, then what will happen?
You can see that, right?
So, uh, for every word
and total number of such thing, that 75,000,
I just can't explore.
Now, what I will do is I will simply write the token
name, okay?
Vocab token token name is, uh, one second.
Sure. Token name is
say one.
Okay? Now see for 1, 1 26,
and that's why here it is assigned as 1 26.
You can check for off.
Also, you can check, okay, for off in my vocabulary,
what is the index given 12.
That's why it is 12 here. Okay?
You can check for the also,
and it is, it is, uh, the, for the, it is 16.
16. Now, you can also check for something, which is,
which might not be there in your vocab support, for example,
uh, I will simply write my name, okay?
Just to check, show you that what will happen soon, okay?
I will run it once again.
Now say that personnel, it is showing one. Okay?
Now, you can actually check that what
what it is written, unknown, unknown.
Yeah, because we have already declared that
for all the unknown token,
what can come will be assigned by the index number.
But yeah, and that is what has happened here.
So you can, uh, in fact, uh, make sure
that this is the same case.
Sorry. You can see that, right? Uh, so that's why it is one.
Okay? Likewise. So now you understood.
So whatever sequence of words you have as a sentence
or as a paragraph in the same way,
it'll return your sequence of indices.
This is called text two indices. Okay? Alright.
Now, once it is done, then you have done the pre-processing,
whatever, now you are ready to apply the sequence of indices
to the model, and model will learn something on of it
till this particular part.
It is just a pre-processing what you are doing in your data,
which is very much required in the case of the text data.
And every text data will have slightly
different pre-processing.
Also, it is not always fixed, like in the case
of image, what happened.
Uh, but, uh, uh, you have certain types of image.
Uh, there also you do some pre set up pre-processing, okay?
Based on what type of image, how is,
what is the size of the image and all.
And, uh, I would say it is in the similar way in
the case of textile.
So, uh, you have to do, um, some, some,
some pre-processing and all.
And this is what is preparing your data,
preparing your data for the model.
Now, is there any query so far? Let me know,
Sir. I have one.
Uh, so, so
this unknown is used in case of, uh, while testing, right?
Uh, yes. Not while training, correct?
Yes, you're correct. Uh, okay.
And also the padding, sir, uh, we usually use it in ff
and then not here. Ah, right.
Uh, you got it very right. Okay. You got it very rightly.
But, uh, I, I,
that's why I said I think I've not used anywhere,
but I have, uh, why then, why I included this token.
So what happens, uh, even in the case of r
and n padding is, uh, can be used
and in fact, people use it how
I was talking about the batch, right?
When you create the batch,
and if the bad badge, when I say it can start with the one,
uh, it will have more than one row and more than one row.
When I say every row may have the different length, no.
When I decided that I will feed five sentence together first
together, when I say first I'll feed the first sentence,
I will get the output, store the loss, then second store,
the loss, third store, the loss means update will happen.
Once I have fed this batch, collective loss,
I have calculated, okay?
And then I can do the back propagation, batch wise, right?
So, but when I'm pro feeding that one,
every sentence in the five sentence,
five rows may have slightly different length
because it text data.
In that case, padding is required.
First sentence has only three words.
Second sentence has five words.
Third sentence has only two words.
Four sentence has four words.
Now, I have decided
that I will put everything in a batch, right?
So in in, in such cases, the padding might be required,
might for that badge itself.
For that badge, I can decide that, okay, I will, I will, uh,
go up to five timestamp every time or,
or something like that, right?
I'll show you that maybe later,
but here, I have not used, here I have not used, yeah.
Search, uh, test for an example, let's say in a badge,
there are five words.
Correct. And then, uh, all the four words have like two
to two to three letters,
and other words have like 10 or 15 letters.
10, correct? Correct. Then if padding is done, uh,
we lose most of the information due
to the zeros, right? Yeah.
The padding always comes with the cost.
I understand that one, it always comes with the cost.
So with the RNA, it is not preferable. Uh Right.
But then if you have very high number of data points,
like 50,000 and of every paragraph is very long,
and if you have the certain resource limit,
and all we do that when, although it is not preferable.
Right. Okay. In the case of the context.
Okay, sir? Uh, do we have any optimization, uh,
cases there, sir?
Uh, optimization in the sense
that the best case is you don't use any padding.
You process each and every text separately.
That is what I have done here in this
particular notebook at least.
Okay. Okay. But then if you want to compromise
with the performance,
because performance will go down as soon,
you'll start using the padding and all. Yeah,
Understood, sir? Yeah.
Thank you.
Excuse Me, sir. Uh, the one, one hot vector,
where can I find this?
I, I'll, I'll, I'll, I'll explain.
Once I'll go to the model part. I'll explain you that. Okay.
Okay. I'm still preparing the data.
So what will happen, these indices, what I, when I have
to suppose in this sentence,
how many times stamp will be created, whatever is the length
of this
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 19.
So 19 timestamp. So every, these are all the words, right?
All these are, the word will will be fed
to the RNN one by one.
Once I'll process one, then I'll process 1 26,
then I'll process 12, then I'll process 16
and so on how the one will be represented.
One will be first represented as a vector,
which is one hot vector, which is a length vocabulary size.
And that will, will pass it to the embedding layer
to further, uh, make it, uh, like dense vector.
Okay? And then we will feed it to the recurrent.
I, I'll explain you that when I'll go to the model part.
Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. Uh, you have taken, um, token
as as words, right?
So I'm just wondering how the Symantec, uh, Symantec aspect
of all these words will come into picture, like the meaning
of one of the other reviewers.
How would the machine would know?
What is the semantic of this sentence?
Uh, so there are two ways in which you can, uh, first
of all, RNN network, what we are going to build,
it'll make the context
because we are going to feed each
of these word one after other.
They will not be processed parallelly
as it happens in the a NN, okay?
So because the RNN is meant
to understand the context, it'll understand.
Secondly, we'll have the embedding layer, embedding layer.
Before giving these word to the RNN,
I will pass it through the embedding layer.
And if you're embedding weights are coming from those word
to way or globe
or fast text, which is already a pre-trained word
embeddings, then maybe these words will have a vector,
which has some semantic meaning in itself also.
Okay? So these are the ways in which you can actually, uh,
preserve the semantics of individual words by its own.
And any way you are going to process one
after another, each word, so they'll have some context of,
so that is how we preserve the context overall.
Make sense?
Yeah. Yeah. One more thing, uh, just to outta curiosity.
Yes. So let's say that sir, one of the practical application
of this, uh, uh, kind of program or this kind of RA network.
Let's assume that we have a PF of, uh,
maybe a hundred pages.
And it would have, each page would have maybe 25
or 30 words.
So can we create an application just
to read all the contents?
And maybe we can ask question
and will the model will be able to answer that?
Can we think of that perspective?
You can. Okay.
First of all, you have to convert the PDF in the form
of the data, what we have.
Okay? You can, you may decide that, suppose you have a book
where you have a hundred pages, right?
You can divide the book as a chapters, as a, as a data
or inside the chapter.
Also, you may have the paragraphs.
So you can treat each paragraph as a rule,
and then you can build the such things
what you have asked, right?
But, uh, with the RNs,
those things would be little bit difficult.
And for RNN,
understanding those huge long context is difficult, okay?
But you can build, having said that,
you can always build such models with RNN as well, okay?
But, uh, current technologies like rag
and doll do those things a little better.
That's the difference.
So when it comes to, um, the, uh, text
of the token overall, um mm-hmm.
Input size, right? So for RNN it can be different, right?
So, ah, correct.
We, and we are not going to use padding to make
It, we are not using that is what is the, uh,
recommended in the RN padding is not required
and you should not use it, okay?
Uh uh. Right?
Although you can always tweak your code,
but then you should not use it otherwise.
RNN, whatever it, it is meant
for handling the variable length inputs. Yeah.
Okay. So, um, even if your network size is going
to be the size of the last, uh, the biggest sentence mm-hmm.
That doesn't matter with the RNN doesn't matter
because IRN works with the time it say that.
Okay? I will simply see that how,
because I'm not going
to process all these words together anyway.
I'll first process one, then I'll process off,
then I'll process though.
So I will go as long as the last token is not coming.
So in, sometimes it may come
after only five times stamp it sometime it may come
after a hundred times stamp.
Doesn't matter for, it'll process everything one by one.
And anyway, the, uh, parameters are going
to be shared across all the times stamp.
So para parameter wise, also, it is not going to be explored
because a hundred times stamps, if there doesn't mean
that a hundred times more parameter will be there.
So that is also not the case, right?
Only problem would be if the sentence length would be very
long, we'll see that later.
First of all, it may lose, uh, uh, the context.
Secondly, it'll be slow in process
because it has to process a hundred
words compared to 500 words.
Obviously, one by one, five times more.
It'll take time if it is a 500 words as compared
to a hundred words like that.
So it is a slow process as compared to the ENN. Yeah.
So in a NN for example, if, if, uh,
there are different sentences with different links,
we pad them Yeah.
And take the maximum and the, uh,
that will be the size of our input.
That will, the size of the Input we feed there.
Also, we feed sentence by sentence.
But here, uh, even if you feed sentence,
it'll be processing word by word.
Word by word, correct? Correct.
So that there their bits, it's gonna be slower.
Yes. Yes. Okay.
Sir. Sir, these indic from X, can we treat these as X,
not X one, X two, or as per E?
Oh, exactly. Yes, yes, yes.
This is the X, no, X one, X two in the architecture,
which we are visual utilizing. Yes. Yes.
What would be u and uh, W server?
Uh, UNW is a connection. Weights.
So suppose now each of these x, no,
X one will be represented
as a vector, one hot vector, right? Okay.
Okay, then. So one hot vector size, suppose it is 1000.
So 1000 into whatever neurons it is connecting.
So that is you. That is you.
And similarly, those neurons are connected
with the next hidden layer neurons.
So suppose there are three neurons in the hidden layer,
the three into three, nine connections.
So those connections, UNW depends on your
how many neurons you are keeping in the hidden layer.
Yes. Okay.
So one question here. Yeah. Uh, can you go a little up?
Yeah. Here, uh, you'll with the apostrophes there,
but then it should come as unknown, right?
But we have it as one 90 index.
Uh, uh, you,
'cause we tokenized it before to remove it,
Right? So you can, you can
actually check,
actually you can check here.
So I will put why, oh, you, U, l, L.
Okay. You can see that it is one 90 there in my vocab.
Uh, why? Because
I have first applied the tokenization
and tokenization itself might have removed this, uh,
apostrophe, okay?
This particular, uh, symbol.
And then it might have become like this.
This is what has happened here. We have seen it right here.
Oh, yeah, yeah. Understood, sir.
I didn't, uh, see that you have used the
function over there in the, here, here.
Context. Yeah.
Here, token. Nice. Yeah, understood, sir.
Yeah, thank you.
Okay. Now, so far, only it,
it was only about the pre-processing.
Now we will go with our pythons usual things.
What we do, first of all,
we always build our custom dataset class,
if you can recall now, right?
Which is inheriting the dataset class, our dataset, uh,
right, uh, class from the PyTorch built in.
And then here we have a constructor.
We have the length function.
We have, so in the data, uh, custom dataset class,
we always define these three function.
Constructor will automatically get executed
whenever we'll create the object of this particular class.
Custom data set class,
and while execution, what I wanted to understand,
what is the input, uh, and MR data frame,
and what is the vocabulary size?
What is the vocab, which I'm going to use, right?
Uh, only thing is here you will see one more.
So DF is my data frame, right?
Where I have the two columns, input
as review, as, and the label.
So that is the df vocab is my vocabulary only thing.
This is different dot reset index. Why?
I am saying, because df, when I selected here, uh, df,
when I selected here,
that was selected randomly 5,000 sample.
So if you will see the df, how does it look like?
It is something like this.
You see, the indices, indices are not 0, 1, 2, 3, 4,
because randomly I have selected 5,000 data,
and these are the rows which it had picked randomly.
So what I'm doing,
because I need to process it later,
what I'm doing here is I'm just think
reset the index, okay?
And drop is equal to true. What does it mean?
Drop is equal to true.
That here, right now, you can see
that the first column is the index column, which is not part
of my data, but if you don't, uh, uh,
I just want to drop this one.
I am creating anywhere the new index.
This is the 0 1 2,
and these are the actual reference
to my data, which I don't want.
So I'm just dropping this column.
I don't want, otherwise what will happen, this will also act
as one of the column in my data, which I don't want,
because this is just an index number.
And that is what it is happening in this particular line.
When I say reset, uh, index.
So in fact, what you can do is if you really want
to check once again, so you can
do these things, right, one by one.
So I can do this one, I can simply write this one.
You see this what has happened?
Same data, but this column index, original index,
where it is dropped, new index is created starting with zero
to 4,900.
This is what I'm doing in that particular line, okay?
Now, once it is done, so I'm telling that
whenever the, uh, object will be created, just do this,
construc execution will be executed.
Then count that, okay?
How many data points we have with the length function.
This is the same what we have discussed earlier also.
Now, finally, I just have to select the items
for the train and test, right?
Uh, not train and test.
In fact, uh, the, the, in the data loader class,
whenever it will ask that, okay, give me these data.
Then this get item function will be called
what this get item function will do.
It'll convert text two indices, this one every row,
which is going for the trained data, trained data
and test data, right?
It'll, it'll get the sentence like this.
It'll convert it into this particular list,
which is a list of indices.
So you can see here, review will be, uh, if we are calling
that function, text two indices.
And what we are doing from the data frame, these locations,
index number will, will be given by the data loader class.
I'm just stretching the review.
I'm switching those, those rows.
Uh, and then the vocabulary, corresponding vocabulary.
So that text two indicis function can be worked
because text two indicis function works two parameter.
First one is the, uh, review.
Second one is the vocab, and that is both I'm giving here.
And similarly, the corresponding labels are also being faced
for that particular index.
So that is what happens. It is just a get item function,
which we have discussed earlier.
So finally, whatever review
and labels will be fetched returning in the form of tensors,
because the PyTorch models will always accept the tens
tensor type data.
That's all. Then I'm just creating one, uh, uh, object
of this particular class, custom class IMDB dataset
by passing my train under DF and vocab.
What is train under DF here? I had done strain test split.
I'm using the strain under df, okay?
And corresponding, uh, uh, corresponding vocab.
I'll feed to that.
That is what, because, uh,
my constructor requires only these two
parameters other than self.
Okay? So that is what I'm feeding here also. Okay?
That is done. And then you can see that once I will, uh,
print the train and the train, uh,
dataset, the first dataset.
Then it looks something like that. So it has two things.
Uh, it has, it has the review, which is this one,
and it has a label, which is this one.
Okay? So this is how it'll be.
And, uh, you can also, I guess, uh,
shape function doesn't work here.
So you can simply print this, okay?
This is just an object, so you can change this
and see for every case it'll different.
This is the review length, okay?
And, uh, this is the, uh, label.
Label is either zero or one. Okay?
So my trained data set is ready.
Now I'm creating the data loader class, trained data set.
I'll feed, okay, batch size.
As I said, I will feed one by one. I want two.
Uh, I don't want to feed in the batch, uh,
which I'll show you later.
Then I will have to use the paddock,
which I'll show you later, but
that will have its own limitations.
So then I'm just creating the data loader class.
By feeding the trained data set
and batch, it'll fetch all the data from the, from the, uh,
data frame, and it'll create the data loaded.
Okay? That's all. Once it is, it, it's done that,
then you can actually see that how my data set has come.
Uh, here, the best size is one, so you can actually, sorry.
Oh, you can actually see the data here.
Uh, uh, here what I'm doing is creating 1 1 4 loop.
And for each batch here anyway, in each batch,
only one data, it is there
that I have defined here, badge is equal to one.
But what it is showing, what is the review?
This is the review tensor and what is its label, okay?
What, what is its review
and what is, uh, it's, it's, uh, shape also.
So review shape, it is printing that.
This particular review has 61 words. 61 words.
So what will the time stamp in which it'll go 61 times X
amount, X one, the next two, the next three,
the next four goes up to 61.
So that is how it'll go. The times stamp is this one.
So it's size is one cross, one cross, 61.
One is the batch size one.
It, uh, uh, one cross 61 that it is a single, single
sentence having the 61 timestamp, okay?
One cross 61. It is this, this one is showing
that what is its label.
Similarly, you can see the second batch.
Here it is even bigger. 3 91 words. It has 3 91 words.
It has label is zero, which is, uh, I guess negative.
So here, 1 73 words.
It has, likewise, you will have every, uh, review
of vari variable length.
Okay? This is how my data looks like after dataset
and dataset loader class, what we have created.
Now, it's time for the model itself.
This is the model, simple RNN model, what
that is the name which we are giving for our custom model,
which will inherit from our NN dot module, uh, class,
which we have already imported up, okay?
And then we have the constructor here,
and we have the forward pass.
These two are the things which we usually do here.
Someone asked, okay, where we represent it
as one hot vector.
So this particular, uh, line, so you see
that this is a constructor, and here this line is calling
the parent class constructor to inherit all the properties
of the parent class neural network.
Right? Now, here we have the actual code, these three lines.
First line is an embedding layer, second line is an layer,
and third line is my linear layer, fully connected layer.
Okay? Third, there are three layers you can imagine.
You can imagine here. So embedding layer, if you see
what is the input dimension, vocab size.
Now, what is the meaning of it?
It means that every token here,
these are all the first token in this second x, no, X one,
X two, like 4, 2, 5, 3 will be represented in the vocab size
vector as one heart vector.
Now, that is by default, the embedding layer, if you will go
and explore and, uh, in pies, uh, it, it works like
that only, right?
So it'll take every token
and it'll represent it in the vocab size dimension.
Vocab size dimension is equivalent to, I guess 75,000
what we have seen up, okay?
Here, cap size, we have already defined somewhere,
I guess vab size was 75,509.
When every index will be represented by the,
this index will be high risk.
All index will be zero. That is what the meaning of it.
Okay? And then this, this input dimension,
it'll convert it into the hundred dimension output.
That's all that in the embedding layer,
you will have a hundred neurons.
It's a neural network.
Embedding layer is also neural network.
Your a hundred neurons, so 75,000 dimensional,
one hot vector will be converted
as a hundred dimensional dense vector.
That is the work of this embedding layer. Okay?
That is the work. So it automatically converts your each
token as that vab size dimension, okay?
That is written in this particular function,
which we are inheriting from an Indo module.
Okay? And then my input becomes a hundred dimension output
of this embedding layer is a hundred dimension,
which is the input of the RNN,
which is the input of the RNN.
Now, this is the RNN layer, okay?
RNN layer a hundred dimension.
So a hundred is an input that each token is represented
as a hundred dimension input.
It'll go to the, uh, hidden layer. In the hidden layer.
How many neurons? We have 64 neurons.
So now you can imagine, right?
I'll just go back and show you what I'm trying to see here.
Here you just see this.
Maybe it'll give you a little more clarity.
So what I'm trying to say is here, uh,
here we have a hundred, like x node is represented here
by four in this particular network.
I have here a hundred. How we have got a
hundred from the embedding layer.
Before embedding layer, it was a VAB size dimension,
but we have reduced it to hundred.
And now in this network, I have a hundred inputs here,
X no is represented a hundred.
Dimension x one will be also represented a hundred,
and all the tokens will be represented a hundred.
How many times it'll go, it depends on the length here,
it'll go 1 73 times.
In this review here, it'll go 3 91 times the time is
stamped, okay?
And we have, it is converting it to 64.
What is the 64 means? This outputs instead of three.
It is 64 neurons are there.
Here also 64 neurons here, also 64 neuron.
How many connection which will between these 2 64,
across 64, these many weights will be used here,
a hundred across 64.
So 6,400 weights will be used in this input
to hidden layer 64.
Across 64 weights will be used between output
to output connection,
and this is the total number of parameter,
and you can add few more neurons, 64 neurons here, that,
that also you can add.
Okay? So these are the parameter which is
constant for the entire network.
Doesn't matter what is the length of the input,
because that is what you're going
to share across all the time stamp.
Okay? So this is a hundred and this is 64. Okay?
Now, that is badge first. True.
It means that usually what happen that, uh, uh,
uh, it is represented as, uh, the badge is at the second,
second position, okay?
Uh, first you have, okay, here it is, it is showing badge,
then timestamp, then it's dimension, right?
So if I'll not do badge first, digital call
to two badge will be here,
and this is the timestamp, something like that.
Or I guess badge will be at the last, something like that.
Badge will be at the last, otherwise.
So, but, uh, the RN accept in this particular way, first,
there should be a batch that what is the batch size,
and then how many timestamp you are going to accept
for that particular batch.
I said, right, for every batch,
your timestamp should be fixed.
Now, because we are fixing here, batch size is equal to one.
You see this by batch side is called two one.
Then you don't have to do any padding.
Every, every input is, uh, in itself is a batch, so
that you can process separately.
Otherwise, for every time stamp,
there should be a fixed batch site.
And in, if you want to, uh, for every batch, you should be,
there should a fixed time stamp, which you want
to process, right?
And then in that case, padding would be required,
which I'm not showing you here, but this is how it's done.
So here, batch first, that is
what you have to do in this format.
You have to create the data.
And, uh, finally, uh, after the RNN,
after the RN means what?
After this layer, you have one more layer.
You have one more layer here,
and this is a fully connected layer, which,
which is a fully connected layer,
fully connected layer in the sense,
suppose I have two more neurons, if I'll keep it here.
Just imagine that two more neurons I'm keeping now
say fully connected layer, right?
So I'm keeping here one neuron and one neuron.
What does it mean? Fully connected.
This will connected with this.
This will be connected with this. All the connection, right?
All the connection, okay?
Here, also, two neurons will come
because each time stamp,
same network, we are going to use, right?
This, this, this, okay?
And, uh, this will also connect it with this.
You can understand right now, the only difference is
because it is a fully connected layer.
This is not the RNN layer, but this is the RNN layer.
This connection, what you're seeing, this connection,
this connection will not be applicable on these two.
In this layer. This connection is true only for this layer,
because this is an RNN layer,
but this is a fully connected layer, okay?
That is the difference. And the fully connector output is
not connected with output here.
This, these two outputs is not connected with these output.
But in RN, these three outputs are connected
with these three, uh, these three output.
Now, that is the difference.
That is the difference, what you will see, okay?
So that is the meaning of this line. Okay?
So 64 will be connected with one final output,
one final output.
Now, uh, uh, this is the classification, which I want to do,
uh, and usually what happen, you know, uh,
this fully connected layer, how you want to build the, uh,
architecture, that also defines, so
what I want while building the architecture, I want
to build the architecture like this that I want
to process x note the next one, the next two,
and here I will put the fully connected layer instead
of putting the fully connected layer here.
Also here, also here also,
does it mean I just want the final sentiment classification
for final sentiment classification.
I'll process the entire sentence,
and then I'll put a fully connected layer here,
and then it'll, it'll, uh, uh, uh,
it'll, it'll say whether it is a positive or negative.
So instead of what I have explained to you,
that fully connected layer here, here, here, uh, uh,
that is not the case in which I'm building this network.
So once all the words are processed,
whatever is the time tamp, then I'm putting one final fully
connected layer, and that is, that will give me one output,
uh, that will tell me
what is the bind binding, positive or negative.
So this is the, uh, this is the architecture
of my simple RNN, and
after that, I'm just using the forward pass.
This is just a blueprint, right, of my network.
This is a forward pass
where first time calling this embedding, passing the X
as a whole review, getting the embedded review,
embedded review will be passed to the
R-N-N-R-N-N embedded review.
It'll give two things. It'll give, uh, this embedded review.
When you'll pass to the RNN, it'll give two output.
First output is for every timestamp,
there is some output, right?
This is the output output coming from this neuron,
this neuron, this neuron,
this is the output from this particular timestamp, right?
So how many, such, uh, output you will get,
suppose in this case, 1, 2, 3, 4.
If there are four timestamp, four output,
individual outputs, you'll get,
and then you'll get one final output.
One final output. I'm interested in one final output.
The fourth output is also the one final output.
I'll show you that. Okay?
Um, I think it's time,
but I will just try to explain you this part,
maybe a few more minutes, and then we'll summarize it.
So what I, I was doing here is, uh, I then I'll,
I call the RNN, and whatever final output will come at,
I'll say under score,
and as final output, that I'll pass it through the, uh,
fully connected layer, fully connected layer,
and then it'll gimme the sentiment.
So this is just a forward pass, which we have created out
of this blueprint of the RNN network.
That's all. Okay?
Now, here, actually, I have showed everything.
What I have told you. First of all,
I'm calling the embedding, okay?
Uh, vocab size is the input dimension, C seven five.
5 0 9 is the input dimension.
Output dimension will be a hundred, okay?
And, uh, actually, I have passed.
So I'm taking my trained data set, uh, trained data set, uh,
and I'm passing it through this X.
What is x? X is representing my embedding layer.
When I'm to this X I'm passing my trained data set of,
uh, this one.
So trained data set looks like this, okay?
It's a, it's a object. So you can say this.
First of all, let me show you this one. What is this?
This is my individual data,
and it's label now,
because I just wanted the review, not its label.
That's why I have put here one more zero this,
because this is what is available as a review.
Then, now, there is no label.
Now, this is my review in the form of tensor,
which I'm passing to the embedding layer x,
X is nothing but my embedding layer.
So once you'll pass it,
process the embedding layer A is giving the output.
Now a, if you see what it is, giving
a is a hundred dimensional output.
So, and a has everything,
but, uh, uh, it's a, it's a,
it's a hundred dimensional output.
So a dot, uh,
I don't know, shape.
So a hundred dime, uh, uh, it's a, it has a, uh,
102 hundred.
That is how it is coming cap, uh, 102 hundred, uh, maybe,
I guess for each of these word,
I think this size is also a hundred.
I don't know. What is this size? Let me see a hundred.
So there are a hundred words, a hundred times stamp, okay?
A hundred, a hundred words is there in my whole data, in my,
in my one, one paragraph, we have a hundred words,
and each of these a hundred words,
which is represented initially as 7,505 50, whatever,
in the vab size, one dimensional vector
converted as a hundred dimensional.
That's why you see
that the output from the embedding layer is
every word like two is represented as a hundred dimension.
Then three is represented as a hundred dimensional.
So this is the representation of two
in the a hundred dimension.
This is the representation of three in the a hundred
dimension, 82.
Now, this is the representation
of 82 in a hundred dimension.
This is what this, this embedding layer does,
takes the one hot vector as an input,
give the embedding dimension vector as an output.
Okay, let me, uh, I will stop here.
I'll leave you, I'll just give you the link of this.
Maybe a few more things are there. Uh, it's nine 15.
Uh, shall I continue for five more minutes?
If it is, okay, then I'll finish it. Yes,
Sir. Yes, sir. Yes,
sir.
Thank you. Thank you. So, uh, yeah,
so embedding will give you the output like that,
and I've shown you its shape is like a hundred across
hundreds because, uh, in this, in this, uh, uh,
zero comma zero, you have a hundred,
but I can change it, right?
I can show you that something else.
So I will do the next, uh, 10th data, 10th data.
I will, I'll just foresee, what is the shape of this data?
So you have 1 98, uh, uh, words in this paragraph.
So for each paragraph, initially it'll be represented
as one hot vector, and then it'll give a hundred.
So 1 98 cross a hundred.
That should be the dimension of my,
that should be the dimension of my embedded vector.
So I will pass hundred 10th, and you see that,
and if you see the shape of this 1, 98, cross hundred,
1 98 are my tokens.
Or you can say words in the whole paragraph, one
by one sequence of words, right?
And then each are represented a hundred dimension.
This is the work of the embedding layer.
Now, when it embedded layer a hundred dimension, so this,
decide how many times stamp it is going to be,
if it's 1 98, 1 98 will be the time stamp for the rrn.
If it's a hundred, a hundred will be the time stamp.
So you can see that RNN can handle variable length input.
That is the, that is what I wanted to show.
Now, you can see here RNN.
Now say that RNN, the same layer I have compete, just
to show you what will be done.
This one I have compete RNN hundred.
It'll be the input, whatever each, each time stamp,
every word or index will be represented at a hundred
dimension that I have made sure
by this embedded dimension, keeping a hundred.
So a hundred will be the dimension, input dimension.
And in this layer, in this layer, I'm using 64 neurons.
So 64 outputs, it'll give, that's why it is 64.
Batch first is called true.
I've already explained without batch first true,
you'll have sequence length, then batch size,
and then input size.
But batch first means first you'll have the batch
size, which is one.
In this particular case, I have fixed it.
Sequence length is 1 98, and input size is this a hundred.
So batch first, just change this sequence, okay?
So that's why this particular parameter,
because RNN accept that in this particular sequence.
Okay? So let us see that what RNN does.
So to the RNN, I'm just passing.
Now my a, a is this, uh, embedded, uh, uh,
a particular input, okay?
And it's embedded representation.
I'm passing it, I'm passing it to this one.
Now, C what I said that in the RNN,
what happened when you process this at the time, stent,
every time a stamp has an output,
so suppose it is 1 98 timestamp, you will get 1 98 output,
and then you will get, so there is one tensor,
which will give 1 98 outputs,
and there is a one more tensor,
which will give the final timestamp output.
You will see here. So why is representing my RNL layer?
And when I'm print passing it,
the A is the output from the embedding layer.
Right here I've shown you a is the output
from the embedding layer.
Okay? So if you see that what it is giving the output,
it is giving two tensor.
One is this sensor, and another one is this
sensor two tensor.
It is given the output, if you observe carefully,
the last one, this particular output, this vector,
is equivalent to this particular vector.
Why? You know, the last timestamp output
is also the representation of whole sentence
or whole paragraph, isn't it?
Is last time done. So whatever it'll give the output.
This is also the representation of whole paragraph.
That's why the last zero point, you can see that 0.6,
0 7, 0, 0 0.5 5, 9 5, uh, same number
and last, then three numbers also are the same.
Okay? So there are two tensors,
which is giving the output from the R-N-N-R-N-N give two
outputs, individual timestamp output.
Also support you required.
Sometimes you require, we'll see that some cases later
or else the last time stamp output, which is in the case
of classification, it is required.
Okay? So I have shown you here also,
so if you will print YA zero part,
then it'll give you the first tenor, which will have
how many outputs equivalent to your timestamp.
Timestamp is 1 98, and you will see that it is 1 98.
And each output is represented at 64 dimension.
So it'll go at 1 98 timestamp, 1 98 times output.
Also, it'll give, and each output shape will be
64 instead of three neurons.
Here we have 64, which we have kept in the RNN.
So 64 dimensional output. That is what it is keeping here.
That is the first output. First tensor, second tensor.
If you see second tensor,
likewise, you can second tensor.
You can see here, it is a single output.
See this on single, how many a single one,
one array with how many?
Uh, one, how many value?
64, because it is only capturing
what is the final timestamp output,
because that is the final representation of whole context,
which is equivalent to the last output.
What is here? This is the output from the RNN, okay?
This is output from now. And then finally
after RN, we are just keeping this, uh, you see that
after, we are just keeping the linear layer.
Linear layer is here at the top, not on these
after processing all these time stamp manner.
And once we get 64 dimensional final vector,
which is a representation of my input,
I'm putting here the linear layer, how many neurons?
One neuron only because I want
to do the binary classification, right?
So here you can see that similarly,
that whatever I'm getting as a, as a B, uh, from, from this,
uh, uh, RNN, I'm passing it to the JJ is nothing
but my, uh, there is nothing
but my, uh, linear layer output layer where I get one,
one tenor as an output, which is the representation of my,
uh, you can say that this, uh,
class is a representation of my class.
Simple. Okay?
So this is just, just to explain you how this, this,
these three lines are working
and how this forward propagation is going to work.
That's why I have explained you all these things internally.
Now, that's all. Once we do that one,
then first I do the model initialization, move it
to this device, which is A GPU, set up the training, uh,
parameter, like what loss I'll use, what optimizer I'll use,
how many ocs I'm using,
and finally the training loop, which, uh, where I'm just,
everything is same.
Here, I'm just fetching review and label from train loader.
It'll go to the custom dataset class, give the index
and face the review
and label, which I'll move, which I'm moving to the GPU.
This thing I've explained to you earlier.
First of all, I'm making all the weights, uh, optimizer,
zero grad, okay?
And then I do the prediction in this line model
and, uh, inside that review, passing
and then converting, uh, the label, uh,
the actual labels, okay?
Because this output is the predicted label.
This label is the actual label, right?
To have the similar size, uh, batch size and cross one.
This is what I'm doing on, on a squeezing operation.
You can see that. Then calculating the loss between output
and the label and doing the backward propagation.
Optimizing means updating all the weights
and finding, calculating the loss.
Once I have run that for the 10 box, you see that how the,
the it, it is running, okay?
Then I can test it for the new sentence also,
which I have not shown, which we'll see that
that late, but you can practice.
Okay, lemme stop here.
I tried to cover that,
how this internal things are are happening.
In the case of these three,
let me know if you have any quick questions
and you can do the practice by your own.
Sir, I have one question. Please tell.
So sir, I did not understand the last part,
the linear 64 comma one part,
And it's good, good, good.
Uh, that you have asked this question.
So it means that, now suppose I have a sentence.
Sentence is RNN viewed as a field forward
network unrolled what?
See, this is a sentence I have
and I have to classify it as a positive
or negative or neutral.
It looks like it's a neutral, right?
So what I want, see,
there are two things in the RNN what I said.
First of all, for every time stamp,
you can get the output I told already, right?
For every time stamp, there is an individual output,
these lines, what you're seeing,
it's an output which you can store,
and I have shown you it is coming and you can store it.
But I'm interested here, I'm interested here
because I want to do the sentiment analysis
of this whole sentence rather than doing the
sentiment analysis of RNN.
So in this X node, X node is my RNN, okay?
In this particular case, what is happening is
X node is my RNN.
Okay? So let me just, uh, do this.
So X node is this, so when I'm processing,
RNN will be processed here
and it'll give some output X one is this, okay?
And likewise, this is my accent,
the last time stem, whatever it'll be.
So what I'm interested is I'm not interested in doing the
sentiment analysis of the individual.
Suppose I'm interested,
then I would have put here also the linear layer,
but actually I'm not interested
any way I'm getting the output.
I could have put it here it is, it is up to me what I want
or not, but I'm not interested in putting the linear layer.
Here I am doing all these processing
for all the time stamp, which is possible.
And then, then putting the, uh, what is that?
Then putting the linear layer here. Linear.
So this is the final timestamp.
I say that final timestamp vector.
What I'm getting here, which is a 64 dimensional output,
it'll have all the understanding about this whole
sentence, whatever I have processed.
Then this vector will be connected with this, uh, uh,
fully connected layer here.
You can keep either two neurons or one neuron.
Both will work. Uh,
and it'll give you the sentiment analysis,
either positive or negative.
Now, this is what is this layer
where 64 dimensional output I'm getting here,
and it is connected with one output,
which is a fully connected, which says
that whether this is a positive or negative plus.
Okay? Makes sense? Got it. Thank you. Yeah, yeah.
Yes, me, sir. Uh, one more question, sir.
So sir, based on this timestamp,
whatever output we are getting, is it correlating
to the formula of it called ht?
Yes. Something times, uh, xt? Yeah.
Here, here, here, uh, here. This one, right?
Yes. Yes. It has to.
Otherwise, how will you calculate this one?
You have to, because every timestamp you do this,
this calculation
for every timestamp you do this calculation, it's nothing
but linear calculation on top of that, some nonlinearity
of your, it's a calculation.
Nothing else.
Yes, sir. Uh, one more question is why do we go
for linear layers here?
Like we can go for logistic, uh
Oh, it's a no, no, no.
I think you have, I, if you have seen my CNN classes,
I've already told actually, it is not a linear layer.
We have, after this layer, we have some activation function.
If it is a binding classification problem, then it, it, uh,
if I'm using only one neuron, then it is a sigmoid.
If it is a two neuron, then it is a softmax,
but that is not shown.
That is already implemented.
Where in the loss function,
actually, I explained that earlier.
So whenever you have b, c, e binary cross entropy with
logistic loss, actually it is applying that, uh,
logic function, whatever it's required,
it is doing that non-linearity.
Yeah. Okay.
It's not a linear, it's linear calculation followed
by the non-linearity logic function. Yeah.
Okay. Excellent. Thanks. Others. So,
So one year question here, sir, for each
of the word embedding is are getting created,
they're creating under embed,
Correct? Correct,
Sir. In the sentence
and sentence for example, is having 15 word,
then it'll be 15 in 200.
So while they are converting into hundred, sir,
and how they are processed in, uh, the networks.
Okay? So again, we'll go back here.
So what happens when your, your sentences are like that,
your initial sentences are like that,
and first you convert them into
one hot vector representation.
Yes, sir. Now, this one hot vector, which is,
it is showing here five values.
In this case, it is 75,000 values I've shown already.
Yes, sir. Yeah. Here, see vocab sizes 75,509.
That means that this vector, which is showing here five,
the v size, V size is here, 75,000.
So now say that there is a word VV is represented
as 75,000 dimensional one heart factor,
where only one value is one and rest all value will be zero.
Yes, sir. So that is the problem.
Now, what I want is I don't want to feed this kind
of input to my RNN.
There are multiple benefit of it.
First of all, if I can feed it, no doubt, I,
I will not use embedding layer.
I'll directly feed it. But what will happen,
how many connection we require here,
how many connection it requires on whatever is the dimension
of your, each word, which is 75,000 into you
and you is 175,000 in 200.
Just imagine. No,
those many connection would be required if you'll directly
process one hot vector.
I have taken a call. I will not process 75,000.
I will first convert the 75,000 into where it was one second
into 100 rate.
So it'll solve two problems.
First of all, it'll reduce a hundred times parameter.
It'll reduce parameter by a hundred times, uh, uh,
75 into one 100 that we were doing.
Uh, now we will only do a hundred into 64.
I think it'll reduce a huge parameter,
not a hundred times, but huge parameter.
Yes, Yes. Secondly, I don't have to process this vector
where all the values are zero.
Rather, I will process this vector, uh, this vector
where some values are negative.
I understand this somewhere, uh,
not this one I've shown, right?
Embedding vector is here.
I can, I have shown you a,
so this vector, this is a hundred dimensional vector, okay?
This is, this is the, another representation of
that one hot dimensional vector through the embedding layer.
So two problem, you know, my huge complexity has reduced
because number of parameter has reduced.
Secondly, the input is also reasonable.
Having zeros is never good.
It's better to have negative
or positive value rather than having zero.
So there are two purpose why I do that. Makes sense?
Yes. Yeah.
Thank you sir. Sir, what is the format, sir?
I mean, how is that 75,000 converted to these uh, numbers?
It, it is just a neural network.
I mean, see, uh, you can imagine that suppose, uh,
No sir, there you were showing those two tens.
No, I mean earlier one vector would be one and all zeros.
Ah, okay. But then you showed that, um, uh,
decimals just now you showed
'cause it's a neuron, right?
I mean, see, you can imagine that this is the neurons, uh,
because neurons can give you any output.
Yeah. So it can be decimal, it can be negative
and can be positive because you're doing what the neuron,
it'll take the weighted sum plus bias
and there is no activation function here.
It's a linear activation function. Yeah,
Linear operations.
Yes. Linear operations.
So it'll give you some decimal value only,
Sir. Um,
so the question is that, uh, the input, the X layer
was, uh, the size
of the X layer was 75,000 something, correct?
Correct. Now with some function, which you showed us,
you have converted that 75,000 into 100.
Correct? So what is that function?
Was what, what I was asking linear
Function. That's what I'm saying. Okay. It's
a linear function.
Like i, I just draw then you will understand maybe I will
take this pen.
So suppose I have here
75,000 diamonds, one hot vector.
Yeah. Okay. So this is the dimension.
You can say 70 5K,
Right? Okay.
70 5K, I'm sorry. Yeah, that's okay. Drawing.
And then here I have a hundred new hundred.
Okay, this is a hundred. What will happen?
It's the fully connected layer actually. Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm. It's a fully connected layer simply
so it's a one out vector.
Mm-hmm. So all the values are zero anyway except one value
where index is high.
Mm. So that index
and corresponding weight will make these neurons,
so give some decimal output, correct?
It's a neuron. Neuron will work. Mm-hmm.
As a neuron, nothing different but neuron,
because it is a neuron, it'll not give you zero
and there is no activation function I'm using it
depends on this weights.
Mm. It depends on this weight.
Suppose this weight is minus 0.28 mm
and this particular whatever, it'll be like 0.2.
That's why it is negative, positive sometimes use. Mm-hmm.
But this is also a neural network.
So instead of the, I mean there's this
fully connected layer
before the actual structure starts. Ah-huh.
Yes, yes, yes. Embedding is nothing
but fully connected layer
before the actual things start. Yes, Uhhuh.
Okay, sir. Thank you sir. Yeah,
So basically we use embeddings to make our input more, uh,
compact and meaningful rather than going for a pass,
pass vector kind of thing, right, sir?
That is one advantage. Second advantage.
It's also reduce your huge parameter,
huge number of parameters.
Yes. The number of parameters get reduced.
Yeah. And uh, yes, that is why it's
So, why it's called weights actually it's just the output
of a neural network, right?
Uh, or what you call it weights.
You said, uh, the embedding values of weights, right? Uh,
Uh, because see when I was explaining this part
that when you have 75,000 dimensional vector
where only one value is one, whatever, they are connected
with these neuron via some weights only, right?
Mm-hmm. Okay. So you just return those
weights as it is in the output.
Is it okay? Yes. Yes.
Except the first value, first value
would be a little different.
It's not really weight assets, right? Or
No, all values because every, uh,
inputs are connected via weights only and this is the neuron
or X is a neuron.
Okay, got it. It's an embedded representation
of your representation.
Okay, Got it. Yeah. So yeah, inputs, yeah,
they're connected with the weights.
Yes.
Uh, sir, uh, last question sir.
Uh, by doing this embeddings,
are we reducing the computation time or the Yes,
because of the decimals, we will have still have trouble.
Oh, no, no, no, no different.
That is a different complexity which you're talking about
that whether a decimal representation is better than the
inte, obviously decimal will take more space.
Float float has the, uh, the,
that more space than the integer.
That is a separate kind of complexity, which you're talking
the complexity which I was talking was in terms
of the number of parameters.
Okay. Okay.
Obviously, uh, if you wish to represent everything
as an in teaser, you can do one more level of wrapping
that everything should be coming
as an in teaser going as an in teaser.
But that will not, that will simply,
you'll simply lose the information if
you will convert every time.
And that is what happened in the quantization.
You must have heard about it in the LLM quantization,
one bit quantization, eight bit quantization.
That is what they do. But you lose the
information also in that case.
Yeah. Okay. But there is separate, uh, complexity here.
We are more majorly focusing on the number
of parameters, how we are decreasing.
Yeah. Okay.
Alright. So I think, uh, now it is more clear
that what is RNN, how it accepts input layer wise,
what is happening inside, why write it timestamp?
And so you just have to do the practice.
Every line you can print and see what is happening.
I have tried to do something you can do even
more than these and all.
So do the practice again.
We'll connect on Saturday, we'll continue,
right? Uh, and uh,
Yeah, sure. Can you share this file?
Yeah, yeah. I'll share, I'll share maybe same file, uh,
RNNI file.
But I will now integrate, uh, the link of this,
uh, this notebook.
Okay. In the same last file, PyTorch, I guess it's, the name
of the file will be PyTorch, D-L-R-N-N-I guess,
but then it'll have the integrated code at the last slide.
I'll share that. Okay?
Yeah, sure, sir. Bye. Thank you sir. Sir,
Thank you so much. Thank you much sir. Thank
Sir.
Thank you, sir.